DON DODGE: Hi.
I'm Don Dodge, and this
is Google Root Access.
Today, I'm going to do a show
on viewer questions.
I did a show a few weeks
ago about, can
startup ideas be stolen?
It generated lots of questions,
so I have a few
here today that I'd
like to cover.
The first question comes
from Nikolai Lind.
And he says, do you guys
agree that software
patent system is broken?
What do you think about New
Zealand's ban on software
patents, and should other
countries copy this approach?
Well, I need to preface my
remarks by saying that these
are my personal views,
not Google's views.
But yes, I would agree that the
software patent system in
the US is broken, particularly
for software.
There are lots of patents
issued that
should never be issued.
The biggest problem
is patent trolls.
Patent trolls are institutions
that acquire patents, but they
aren't real companies,
so they call them
non-practicing entities.
They acquire patents and then
turn around and sue startups.
They sue startups because
startups don't have a lot of
money and can't defend
themselves, so
they're easy prey.
Then after winning several of
these suits against startups,
they start going after bigger
and bigger companies because
they have some case
law behind them.
So yes, it is a big problem.
And there are organizations
in the US--
the Application Developers
Alliance is one, the
Electronic Freedom Foundation
is another--
that are trying to fight
these things.
I'm not familiar with New
Zealand's ban of patents and
how that works.
But not all patents are bad, so
I think it's dangerous to
totally ban patents.
Patent reform is probably
the better approach.
Our second question comes from
Keith Trinka, and he says,
what do you guys think about a
startup versus a skunkworks
type inside of a
larger company?
Would you expect one to be more
innovative or successful
than the other?
That's a good question.
Innovation doesn't matter
where it starts.
The bigger question is, once
that innovation is done, where
will it be more successful, in
the context of a startup or in
the context of a
larger company?
My opinion is that startups
are all in every day.
So they're taking big risks.
They're totally committed to
this idea, and they innovate
and make it happen.
When it comes time to take that
innovation to market,
again, they're totally committed
and all in, so the
chances that they're going
to be successful
are probably better.
Innovation can happen
at a large company.
And there are skunkworks and
research labs and things like
that where innovation happens,
but those innovations are
typically focused on
the core business.
So they're longer-term projects
or innovations to a
core feature or product
of the company.
And as long as those line up
well, then that can be very,
very innovative and seamlessly
added to the product and be
very successful.
Where it hasn't been
successful is--
probably the biggest example
is Xerox PARC.
Xerox PARC had one of the most
famous research labs in the
world that developed things
like the graphical user
interface and the mouse and
all sorts of other amazing
innovations, laser printers,
I believe.
And those innovations didn't
line up with the corporate
goals or the corporate
product strategy.
So all that great innovation
went to waste and never saw
the light of day.
So I think innovation can happen
anywhere, in a startup
or in a skunkworks in
a large company.
But taking that innovation to
market is where it falls down
and where startups are better
than large companies.
Another question came from
The Novice Mind.
Interesting username.
What advice do you give startups
for dealing with the
legal minefield, such as
copyrighted user content or
other legally concerning
areas that can
appear from user content?
Another good question.
You may recall I was vice
president of Napster, the
music company, and we had a few
issues with user content.
However, in that case, it was
not user-generated content, it
was user-contributed content,
and there's a big difference.
User-generated content is
generated by the user and,
typically, has no
copyright on it.
Sometimes, however, a
user-generated content piece
will include something that is
copyrighted, and that's where
you run into trouble.
But there are safe
harbor areas.
There's the Digital Millennium
Copyright Act that covers
copyrights, and it gives safe
harbor to software companies
who are, like, discussion boards
or sharing places and
that kind of thing, where you're
not responsible for
what the users put
on the site.
There are procedures called
takedown notices, where anyone
who sees copyrighted information
that they own can
notify you, as the site
owner, and say,
hey, that's my content.
It's violating my copyright.
Take it down.
And then you have to investigate
that and take it
down within a certain
number of days.
So as long as you do that,
you're in the open and not
liable for any copyright
infringement.
If there's rampant copyright
infringement, and that's all
you do, such as the case in
Napster, then you're going to
get vicarious copyright
infringement and aiding and
abetting copyright infringement,
and that's where
you get into big trouble.
So as long as your site or app
has significant legal use and
can be used for other things,
and there's just a small
amount of copyright
infringement, you can handle
that with a safe harbor and
deleting the copyright
information.
If not, then you have
larger problems.
I'm not a lawyer, so I don't
give legal advice.
That's just an opinion and
based on my experience.
All right.
So keep these viewer
questions coming.
They're very interesting, and
I'll try to answer as many of
them as I can in future shows.
So thank you, and join
us next time.
But before you go, I have a
special offer for you, for
Google Root Access
users, viewers.
We have a $2,000 credit
on Google Cloud.
So if you're developing an
application that uses a cloud
backend, I encourage you to try
Google Cloud, and here's
$2,000 for free to try it.
The information on how to get
that credit is appearing on
your screen.
Thank you very much, and
see you next time.